if you look to the sky this week you'll
be able to see a pretty unique site
around Sunset that's something called a
conjunction Brian will spoke to the
Astronomical Society of Nevada and has
the details on what you'll be able to
see
maybe from the strip it might be hard to
find in the suburbs of Vegas you'll be
able to see those looking Due West the
two brightest planets in our solar
system Jupiter and Venus are coming
together for the first time in several
years 2016 was the last time that this
happened so that's seven years ago
astronomically that's just a blink of an
eye Jim Fahey a retired science teacher
and member of the Astronomical Society
of Nevada says these occurrences happen
periodically because our planets are all
circling the sun on the same plane Venus
has phases it will never show up as a
complete circle because it orbits inside
the earth and that Dynamics never lets
the sun fully illuminate so you have the
sun Venus and Earth and so you can never
have a truly fully lit Venus is the same
thing happen for Jupiter or is that just
no Jupiter is beyond us so if you have
that flashlight effect Jupiter is always
uh a fully lit Circle and when planets
come together like this it's called a
conjunction and something we can see
from Earth you'll be able to see this
optical illusion every night leading up
until March 1st that's when Jupiter and
Venus will be at their closest point
which to us they'll look like one object
but they'll still be 400 million miles
apart
ah very cool Brian will well if you miss
out on seeing this conjunction you can
catch these other astronomical events
this year a total eclipse of the sun
this spring from Texas to Maine and a
solar eclipse happening this fall on
October 14th